I'm in the mood for pancakes this morning
and my dad brought me flour from Germany,
so now we make pancakes together.
There is no recipe for this.
I'll just take 2 eggs.
Let's start with the eggs.
I burned myself up here too,
with my straightening iron this morning.
Normally I would use n rod mixer,
but I don't have one,
so I use the mixer.
Let's put a little milk in it.
I don't have vanilla sugar,
so I'll just take vanilla extract.
I use spelt flour.
That's how my dad used to do them when we were little.
I think we'll start with that.
This is the consistency we are looking for.
Just warm up the pan and then I put some
butter in it and then we put our dough in it.
I did not succeed in the 1st pancake.
We'll try right at the 2.
This is now our 2.
Try.
People said yesterday,
thanks dad.
I always make applesauce on the pancake,
but I also made n few days ago raspberry sauce,
so I make the also still on it.
This is what the whole thing looks like then.
Sometimes I put powdered sugar on it,
not today and this is how I make my German pancakes.